what we're going to do now is start to
explore a series of tests to determine
whether a series will converge or
diverge and the first one I'm going to
go through right now is perhaps the most
basic and we'll hopefully see the most
intuitive and this is the divergence
test and the divergence test won't tell
us if a series will converge but it can
tell us if something will definitely
diverge so first let me write it in kind
of mathy notation and then we'll look at
an actual concrete example of it so the
divergence test tells us that if if the
limit as n approaches infinity of a sub
n does not equal zero then then the
infinite series going from N equals 1 to
infinity of a sub n will diverge will
diverge and we've already gone through
what it means the divers that this sum
is either going to go unbounded to
positive infinity or unbounded to
negative infinity or it'll just
oscillate between values it'll never
really approach a given sum or given
value so that's what the divergence test
tells us and you're probably thinking ok
all right I can kind of get what this
says but where is this actually useful
and to see where it can be useful let's
look at a candidate series and see if we
can figure out if it's going to diverge
so let's say I had the series so the sum
from N equals 1 to infinity and in
general it doesn't always have to be N
equals 1 it could be N equals 5 it could
be N equals 0 the key is is that this is
an infinite series that we're talking
about so that's why we care about the
limit as n approaches infinity and so
let's say we have the sum of for N
squared minus n to the 3rd over 7 over 7
minus 3n to the third
are so given what we know about the
divergence test is this series going to
converge or diverge well let's just look
at this this let's look at what take
what we're taking the sums of so this is
essentially or this is our a sub n if
we're trying to match to the the
definition or I guess the explanation of
that divergence test so let's think
about what the limit the limit as n
approaches infinity of for N squared
minus n to the third over seven minus
three and to the third is and I
encourage you to pause the video and
think about that well there's a couple
of ways to think about it one way say
look as n goes to infinity the highest
degree terms of the numerator in the
denominator are the ones that matter and
so this is going to approach negative n
to the 3rd over negative 3 and to the
3rd which will just be which would
approach negative 1 over negative 3
which would be which would really
positive 1/3 or we could say if we want
to do a little bit more or do a little
bit more systematically limit as n
approaches infinity we can divide what
the numerator and the denominator by n
to the third so if we divide the
numerator by n to the third this first
choice it's going to be 4 over N minus 1
over 7 over n to the third minus 3 and
here it becomes clear the limit as n
approaches infinity that's going to go
to 0 that's going to go to 0 and so
you're going to be left with negative 1
over negative 3 which is equal to 1/3 so
notice the limit of a sub n as n
approaches infinity in this case is not
equal to 0 therefore this sum will this
infinite series will diverge diverge now
let's take for a second why this makes a
ton of sense well the only way that
you're going to converge you're going to
settle you what we're doing you're doing
an infinite sum you're taking an
infinite sum of things so the only
reasonable way that something might be
able to converge to a finite values if
every extra term you're adding is
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
is approaching 0 if as n approaches
infinity you you go unbounded or if it's
even equal to one-third
this means that for very large ends you
just keep adding things that are getting
closer and closer to one third well if
you add an infinite number of one thirds
together you're going to go to infinity
you're going to be unbounded you are
going to diverge so that's all that's
telling us look in order for something
to converge after doing an infinite sum
of them at some point these things are
going to get really really really close
to zero if at some point they're not
getting close to zero
there's no way it's going to converge
that thing will diverge so hopefully
that makes a little sense and that also
gives us another insight on what that
first test can to do the divergence test
can be used to show that something will
diverge but but if something I guess you
could say passes the divergence test it
doesn't or if I guess it or I guess
fails the diverge this 2's or if the if
this isn't true it doesn't mean that the
thing is going to converge and so let me
give you an example of that so this
right over here from N equals 1 to
infinity of 1 over N and this is
actually the harmonic series right over
here this if we look at if we try to
apply the divergence test we would say
okay well what's the limit as n
approaches infinity of 1 over n well way
that is 0 as n approaches infinity this
is equal to 0 and so we could say well
it's it's kind of failing the divergence
test so we're not just by using the
divergence test we can't prove that this
thing is going to diverge but that
doesn't mean that it doesn't diverge it
actually turns out and we we prove this
in several videos it actually turns out
that this thing does diverge this thing
does does diverge it's just that the
divergence test isn't enough it's not as
enough of a tool to let us know for sure
that this diverged you will see the
comparison test and the integral test
can either be used to prove that this in
fact does diverge and so you can't you
can definitely not say that if something
if this does not apply for something if
you're taking the limit as n approaches
infinity and it does go to 0 that's the
thing still might diverge it doesn't
necessarily mean that it converges now
there are things that do converge that
where they do approach 0 so for example
if I take the sum from N equals one to
infinity of one over N squared if I try
to apply apply the divergence test I
have the limit as n approaches infinity
of 1 over N squared well this does equal
zero this gets really really large this
thing is going to approach zero and so
once again this is I guess failing the
test for divergence just with that alone
you don't know for sure that this thing
is going to converge it still might
diverge the divergence test just might
not have been enough now it does turn
out and once again we prove this in
future videos that this thing does
converge this thing does converge but
not because not because it I guess you
could say fails the divergence test we
have to use a different test to show
that this does in fact converge just as
we have to use a different test to show
that this does in fact diverge where the
divergence test is useful is for the
things that actually pass the divergence
test when you actually find that the
limit as n approaches infinity of a sub
n does not equal zero like this case
right over here in this case that a
vergence test helps us because we helps
us make the conclusion that this series
definitely definitely die the series
definitely diverges